PEGI 12
my name is Thomas Johansson and I'm the
project lead for European resource for
and I'm going to tell you a little bit
about our upcoming expansion called
wealth nations the main focus is trade
and one other thing that makes trade
great for me is that it really drives
directions for conflict and that's
really something that we want to
strengthen further so with wealth
nations we won't give the player more
tools to create conflicts first of all
we're going to allow you to fabricate a
reason for a trade war and then we're
also changing how trade wars work we're
also looking at trade republics
I mean merchants republics in year four
they were they had lots of cool bonuses
but the roles bit weak because they're
really small like the nation of Venice
for example out just as the coastline so
we figure that you know why keep these
people around so we're giving actually
giving them another new bonus if a
merchant Republic trades in an area
where you own provinces that's not just
a loss for you instead it will boost
production in that province you will
have to feel that how much money do they
steal from me and how much production do
I get back should I fight them or
shouldn't like another really
interesting thing that we're adding for
wealth nations in history people hired
privateers to go out and hijack other
people's ships and we figure we can have
this too we added a new mission that you
can use your trade ships for less called
privateers and you send them out on a
mission like you do with a trade mission
but instead you send one privateer
mission that it means that you're not
getting so much money but they're going
to be worth about one half twice as much
trade power that used to be so it's a
great way for a small nation to hit a
bigger nations trade above their weight
so to speak or if there is a port on map
where you can't direct trade back home
to you then that's also something you
can do right and the final thing I
wanted to mention is that we're going to
do something called trade companies and
in the previous expansion and conquest
of paradise
we added colonial nations where colonial
nation was independent and could create
problems for you they expanded on their
own and we want to do something
different with trade companies so trade
companies is something that you have in
places like Africa and East
yarn India a Miskin places where you
assign provinces to your trade company
as you do that these provinces will be
worth much more in trade power but much
less in manpower and taxes so it's
become a way of specializing your
trading empire and then we also one
thing we haven't talked about before
that we're adding newly is that when
your neighbor nations are more primitive
than you they can use this and do
something because they can Western eyes
they can learn new things but if their
neighboring through trade company they
can't do that anymore so your presence
isn't so marked in India for example if
you have a trade company like I said we
have mostly trade but we try to put in
other interesting things in our
expansion that we feel the game is
needing and what we're doing now is you
wanted to make it a little bit more
interesting to play Nations in India so
what we're doing is that we're adding
lots of new events for Indian nations so
if you play Hindu ruler you're going to
get much more local feeling to the whole
thing and we're also adding a special
specialized mechanic for the Hindu
religion where you can actually choose
which deity to follow and that's going
to have effects on your country this
expansion isn't going to be a bit about
big strokes this one is going to have a
lot of different changes and of course
there's going to be a big patch where we
add a bunch of free features at the same
time as we released expansion and one
thing I can tell you about is that we're
completely redoing the rival system
picking rivals is actually something you
have to do but a big choice because if
you don't fight your rivals that's going
to impact you badly and and you're
something that we call your power
projection will suffer wealth nation is
going to make trade much more
interesting but it also kind of change
the way people play you for in a lot of
aspects
you